jeder tag den dieser krieg weitergeht
kostet dem russischen staat und den
präsidenten sehr viel erster sehr viel
geld die rede ist von bis zu 20
milliarden dollar pro tag zweitens
menschliche verluste von den soldaten
die so nicht einkalkuliert waren
natürlich auch die technik aber am
wichtigsten ist jeder tag kostet auch
zustimmung in russland es sehr schwer zu
erfahren wie viele menschen in russland
überhaupt diesen krieg befürworten aber
klar ist die zweifel wachsen führende
russische politiker fangen an sich zu
rechtfertigen was sie sonst nie tun
anstatt in angriff eben in
verteidigungshaltung übergehend und das
ist für mich ein klares zeichen dafür es
wird bald einen waffenstillstand geben
morgen sind schon verhandlungen die
werden noch nicht zum erfolg führen aber
nach 23 runden von verhandlungen werden
wir an den waffenstillstand sehen den
kunden als sieg verbuchen wird wollen
dieser sieg wird aber ein pyrrhussieg
sein es wird ein sieg sein der so teuer
erkauftes wie keiner und dieser sieg
wird am ende möglicherweise zu
niederlagen von wladimir putin führen
herr kofler sie haben ja auch freunde
und familie sowohl in russland als auch
in der ukraine
wie geht es den menschen vor ort und was
wird die ihnen mitgeben auch mit blick
auf die these die sie gerade vertreten
haben ganz wichtige botschaft die ich
bekommen habe aus moskau als ich sagte
ich komme in diese sendung was soll ich
denn sagen hat mein geschäftspartner mir
gesagt sagt bitte putin ist nicht
russland seit bitte die sanktionen die
jetzt kommen ja wir können das verstehen
die treffen aber auch uns einfach nur
menschen hier auch gerade die die selbst
liberal sind die gegen ihn eingestellt
sind wir verstehen das alles aber es tut
wirklich weh aber bitte nicht alle
russen stehen hinter diesen krieg und
unterscheidet zwischen dem präsidenten
und dem volk übrigens etwas was ja olaf
scholz in seiner rede auch sehr sehr
klar gemacht hat aus der ukraine ist
natürlich klar jede unterstützung die
bisher angekommen ist große dankbarkeit
niemand sagt zu spät zumindest nicht von
meinen kontakten und dann bitte noch
mehr von kathrin die jetzt in polen ist
soll ich den zuschauern in deutschland
ausrichten wenn ihr jetzt nicht kämpft
dann wird das böse zu euch kommt ist so
eine sehr klare position also so gesehen
kein einziger von meinen kontakten hat
mir auch in russland sagen wollen dass
er diesen krieg unterstützt
paul du hast die these von der auflage
rat würde es zu einem pyrrhussieg com
wird putin geschwächt aus diesem krieg
hervorgehen
also erst einmal bin ich leider muss ich
sagen nicht so optimistisch was ein
schnell waffenstillstand angeht und zwar
deshalb weil
wladimir putin diesen sieg unbedingt
braucht und es ist nicht so leicht das
ganze als sieg darzustellen wenn er zb
kiew nicht erobert hat das bedeutet dass
er schwerste waffen einsetzen muss und
das bedeutet auch dass weitere
zivilisten sterben werden und das wird
natürlich die wut und die emotionalität
was die
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen angeht
ebenfalls prägen und schon allein
deshalb wird es ganz schwer sein
irgendeine lösung zu finden weil ja auch
kein premierminister mehr mit wladimir
putin redet und wenn ich mir vorstelle
dass er in diesen krieg gezogen ist das
muss man ja immer wieder sagen mit der
begründung dass die ukraine zu russland
gehört also dass er der ukraine das
existenzrecht abgesprochen hat und ganz
klar die gesamte das gesamte land unter
seine kontrolle bringen will da ist es
schwer vorstellbar wie die ukraine
darauf in irgendeiner form reagieren
soll es ist ja nicht so wie die
optimisten sozusagen so grausam das
klingt in diesem kriegsfall gedacht
haben dass er sozusagen nur in
anführungszeichen teile des ostens
versucht hat zu bekommen sondern eben
das ganze land selbst lemberg hat schon
angriffe luftalarm erlebt also ich weiß
nicht wie die verschiedenen seiten an
einen tisch kommen sollen und
tatsächlich unterschreiben können
woraus in irgendeiner form einen plan
für das land aufhält
ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau würde dem
extrem zustimmen was paul ronzheimer
gesagt hat weil es wenn es um die frage
geht was putin aus einem
waffenstillstand aus
friedensverhandlungen mit rausnehmen
kann extrem darauf ankommen was das sein
wird und
putin steht ja mit dem rücken zur wand
muss man ja schon sagen es ist
eigentlich die große schlacht für ihn
die muss er gewinnen oder er ist weg vom
fenster es dann als kreml-chef weg vom
fenster möglicherweise muss er dann eine
niederlage wie auch immer sie aussieht
auch mit dem persönlichen leben bezahlen
das geht in russland ja zum teil auch
ganz schnell also
also ein pyrrhussieg sehe ich etwas was
soll der pyro sieg sein also und wir
haben doch gerade ja gehört die frage
lässt putin sich abspeisen er wird er
noch ordentlich einen drauf legen
also ich bin leider auch nicht so
optimistisch aus zwei gründen
friedensvertrag heißt ja zunächst mal
die waffen schweigen das ist ja erstmal
gut das töten hört auf aber wie geht es
denn danach weiter wie soll er begründen
dass er die waffen schweigen lassen
welcher begründung weil er ja sagen wir
fahren nur zwei ein erster begründung
ist entmilitarisierung der ukraine damit
ich damit ich bin jederzeit wenn die
ukraine nicht spurt wieder unter meiner
kontrolle bringen kann oder aber ein
marionettenregime ein regime was von
seinen gnaden abhängig ist putin wird
sich nicht zurückziehen also
waffenstillstand friedensvertrag und
jetzt sehen wir uns wieder zurück aber
für das marionettenregime muss er ja den
see lance gestürzten das heißt er muss
in briefen einmarschieren genau er muss
also schon kiew einnehmen alles darunter
und ihren augen putins kein galasek und
würde eben nicht ruhm und ehre in
russland einbringen das kann ja sein ich
an dich schon wäre ich hätte eine frage
ja
aber bei der vorstellung dass man das in
seinem geliebten schwerste waffen
eingesetzt werden also diese vorstellung
kann ich mir einfach beim besten willen
nicht bildhaft vorstellen und ich glaube
das wäre auch etwas was einem da die
mädchen auch in russland nicht verziehen
würde
aber da muss ich direkt mal ein haken
also
bislang haben sie recht sind nicht die
waffen eingesetzt worden den haag tief
eingesetzt wurden aber es gab
raketeneinschläge in dem größten
hochhaus der stadt zum beispiel gerade
eben wurde der tv turm angegriffen dabei
sind fünf menschen ums leben gekommen
ich habe die bilder gesehen grausame
bilder der getöteten menschen dort
deshalb was macht aus ihrer sicht den
unterschied zwischen haki wo wir diese
unfassbare bombardierung gerade in
diesen momenten minuten wo wir sprechen
erleben warum sollte er das nicht auch
in kiew tun weil ich glaube ansonsten
wird er diese stadt ja nicht einnehmen
können was soll er denn tun hat und dann
habe ich es vielleicht falsch verstanden
als ich hörte denn das ist ja noch etwas
anderes ausmaß also das was sie auch
relativ gesehen haben wo natürlich ist
tote gab aber mit einem ausmaß von apple
noch nicht
ja ja sie ich glaube sie machen da einen
fehler sie vergleichen aleppo sozusagen
wie wir diese bilder im kopf haben am
ende des krieges wo alles kaputt gebombt
wabern aleppo hat es ja irgendwann auch
einmal angefangen wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen dass dieser krieg gerade
einmal sechs tage alt ist in aleppo
wurde jahrelang gekämpft ich hoffe und
bete wir hören jetzt in diesem moment
und sie erleben ist live mit luftalarm
wieder hier in kiew
das bedeutet dass es wieder anschläge
geben kann und der ja das ist sozusagen
hier ein ziel geben wird nämlich das
gebäude des geheimdienstes
solange wir kein zweiter alarm höheren
bleibe ich bei euch aber das ist das
gefühl ich bin mal ganz ruhig hört mal
rein
das ist live aus kiew in diesem moment
das ist das was alle menschen in diesem
moment in vier fällen sirenenalarm
mehrfach am tag meistens tatsächlich
jetzt am abend hier ist es eine stunde
später als bei euch und
das ist etwas was man sich
in dieser stadt auch nicht hätte
vorstellen können was bedeutet was der
unterschied zwischen erster alarm und
zweiter lahm ich muss ehrlich sein wir
nicht erst alarm höhere würde ich mir
wünschen dass sie jetzt direkt aus der
kamera hier bei mir im studio
verschwindet wo liegt der unterschied
wir haben hier wo wir sind sozusagen
noch weitere
warnsysteme und da kann ich jetzt aus
sicherheitsgründen nicht eingehen aber
wir sozusagen suchen den weg in den
keller wenn da ein zweites
warnsystem angeht und sozusagen nicht
ausschließlich diese luft sirion ist
aber tatsächlich
ist es so dass viele viele menschen
jetzt in diesem moment gerade wo sie
zuschauen wie in den keller gehen kinder
ältere auch das vergisst man die sind
alle noch hier sind viele zivilist noch
hier nicht alle einige oder viele am ort
versucht zu flüchten aber ich habe heute
auf den straßen auch mit vielen sprechen
können die sich eingedeckt haben mit
lebensmitteln um schnell sich zu wappnen
dafür dass möglicherweise hier die stadt
eingekesselt wird die schlangen von den
lebensmittelgeschäften in kiew sind ja
schon sehr sehr lang und die frage ist
natürlich wie lange kann man das
durchhalten so eine riesenstadt mit
lebensmitteln zu versorgen
wenn irgendwann der nachschub eben
ausbleibt
das ist richtig
und das ist sozusagen
das ist sozusagen ich habe gerade mein
kameramann yorkers übrigens jedes motiv
ist den ich mal hier auch reif loben
möchte immer mit mir unterwegs seit mehr
als zehn jahren wirklich guter freund
und bester kameramann den man sich
wünschen kann was die versorgung angeht
ja das ist ein großes problem und vitali
klitschko sagt es auch das
ich weiß wie lange die versorgung
funktioniert klitschkos dafür zuständig
aber die logistik auf den straßen heute
haben wir an einer brücke fast vier
stunden
gestanden weil an diesen check points
die zivile verteidigung der stadt
wahnsinnig nervös ist um herauszufinden
wer ist wo wenn man davon ausgeht dass
russische provokateure unterwegs sind
auf den straßen und deswegen
funktioniert diese logistische
verschiebung nicht mehr richtig